Bruce Feldman Fox Sports the athletic
college football writer join us to give
us some perspectives this a fair pay to
play act in California
I guess the NCL n-c-double-a says it's
harmful and unconstitutional would upend
the balance of national competition in
college sports Wow
this is not so if it passes not supposed
to take effect until 2023 what else can
you tell us about this Bruce yeah it's
really unwieldy dad and I think the NCAA
is really scared of it Mark Emmert the
president has come out and really tried
to make some threats about it and I
think talking to folks all over the west
coast who work in college athletics I
think the thing that they're scared of
is the unintended consequences they
think that will come with this and what
we're talking about is some of the stuff
that I think gives them the most concern
is doing deals with card shows and doing
deals with what you might call the
low-hanging fruit yet you know some you
know you see you see a lot of people do
where it's like okay how do you monitor
that kind of money where it comes from
is this going to be an easy easier way
for boosters to funnel money to players
and I think that's the part there they
know that that's going to be a big
problem for them in this but but this
hole in name image and likeness thing
that's coming down the pipe the MTA
really is tried to get tried to get a
handle on it and they're really not able
to do it and I feel like you said it's
2023 it's really unwieldy and I don't
think anybody knows really where it's
headed at this point and what the NCAA
can do about it because at this point
the NCAA knows it always loses the
public relations battle on this front
especially when everybody else is making
a fortune including you know us and the
TV business on it and the
student-athletes while they're getting
an education that's not insignificant
people are looking at go there's got to
be a better way to deal with this yeah
I'm just trying to understand how you
can do it how you can monitor it make it
above board and I have no problem with
these athletes cashing in on their image
and their likeness because it is their
image and their likeness
the ed O'Bannon lawsuit does that factor
in at all with where we are in
California
it does and I think some of the things
that are kind of butted into this I mean
look the NCAA is has tried to get at its
rules of amateurism and right now
there's a working group that's that's
looking at recommendations Jean Smith
who's the ad at Ohio State is one of the
most powerful people in college sports
he's you know he's on that committee as
is the Big East Commissioner Val
Ackerman and I think what they're trying
to figure out is okay do we is there a
new model we can put forward that can
release make this a little more
manageable because right now the
O'Bannon stuff I think there's been a
lot of cases that are that are coming I
don't say come into a head but they're
coming down the pipeline and I think
what the NCAA is really struggling with
is you know what happens with like how
do we get control of this because it is
just right with the opportunity for to
be it not to be and that's so like just
use the word exploited but just take an
advantage of where the amateur model and
some would call it a farce already but
they're still trying to hold that model
in where is the the players are not
there are amateurs and everybody else is
professionals and so once that comes to
it and somebody says and now these
recruits are much better known as as
commit as commodities when they're
coming up in high school you know
through Twitter and social media they're
all they're much more accessible so
here's the opportunity for a lot of
people to identify them as as this five
star this four star what they're worth
is and I think that scares a lot of
people not just the NCA I think it
scares a lot of people who work at the
universities and the athletic
departments about that too it all it
takes is one state to do it and then you
can guarantee you you know Ohio Alabama
you know you're gonna have these
different states where you have you know
Michigan where hey we got to keep up
with them and then it feels like you
know it's like I mentioned it's like
sports gambling or marijuana
you know once one state does it and then
we see what the benefits are and then
another state or you have to keep up
with you know these other you know you
have to keep up with us see that you
know they're gonna get players and I
think it's even more problematic than
than the marijuana law is for for
universities because in a lot of ways I
think what they look at it is the
biggest threat to them and we see this
in the basketball scandal that's been
you know going on for like two plus
years is the NCAA is holding on to a
model which a lot of people look at
it'll come on let's be honest there's a
lot of cheating that goes on and I
talked to a lot of a lot of coaches
around the country who think the
cheating and college football right now
is as bad as it's ever been and again I
think that goes back to what I said a
minute ago about how these recruits and
commodities of what they are now are
more well known and more people know
about them and the dollars are bigger so
I think that's where this thing gets to
be so messy for them and there's just so
many different more ways people could
start the system and quite honestly
cheat the rules and again I think what's
different here is what's a rule versus
what's a law and that's something that
the NCAA has always kind of tried to
sneak its you know hands around and has
it's harder and harder for the NCAA to
do that
Bruce good to talk to you I know we got
a little time before this is put into
play if it is ever put into play it's to
me it's not a matter of if it happens
but when but you know they're looking at
2023 thank you Bruce as always and said
Bruce Feldman Fox Sports he also writes
for the athletic college football for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]